the attack was carried out during
morning rush hour as many people were
going to work and university students
heading to campus the bombs exploded at
a security checkpoint used by many
coming into Mogadishu a truck loaded
with explosives was detonated at a busy
checkpoint the explosion led to many
deaths and injuries most of those died
here are students who were going to
their schools and universities officials
say many of those killed by the truck
bomb were University students the
explosion was very large it was close to
where the 2017 bomb happened many people
died here especially students I saw many
dead bodies lying on the ground in my
eyes some of the dead were police
officers but also students were killed
officials believe the target was a
building next to the checkpoint being
used by government troops the group
al-shabaab was pushed out of Mogadishu
several years ago but it still targets
high-profile areas such as checkpoints
and hotels al-shabaab was also carried
out attacks in neighboring Kenya and
Uganda smileys government says it's
trying to stop attacks like these from
happening but for those caught up in the
blast and those who lost family members
and loved ones that's a little comfort
now Jairo Matassa al-jazeera